another way to help on this blackout
Tuesday and Beyond supporting black
owned businesses
we have several black owned restaurants
around town and rocky is at one that
will keep you full and healthy too rocky
yes full and healthy we'll get to the
food in just a minute but of course like
you guys have been encouraging if you
want to help the community and the cause
right now it's really just a simple way
is to give back to black owned
businesses and we have so many here one
owned by this lovely lady safety Dugan
hi now let me introduce you to her she
is a gourmet vegan and raw food chef and
nutritionist yes okay also covergirl so
if we can pull she was featured on the
cover of Las Vegas entrepreneurs
magazine yes tell us about your journey
and how you got here so of the container
park location is simply clear we're
located and down inside downtown
container park and we've been here for
almost seven years in December and my
talking so we are we were a part of the
downtown project as far as we were
cooking for Tony Hsieh who is also the
president Saddam what was the president
of the downtown project at the time we
were cooking for a bunch of people and
they found out about us and wanted and
asked if we wanted to move into
container parkland and open and we say
yes and wow the community has been
amazing for us over the past six and a
half years and we're here and we're
stronger than ever because of our
community and we're super grateful so so
so how can our community actually help
you guys and the black owned businesses
and
absolutely well first come on down
matter where you decide container park
we're open we have all kinds of healthy
food and then we also have a meal prep
surface where we started a buy one gift
one program so every week we offer a
meal prep people order meals through our
website that they can take home and
reheat and eat throughout the week and
every time someone purchases a meal from
our meal prep program then we donate a
meal to a family or individual who's
been affected by the pandemic and it's
been going extremely well we started
that at the beginning of April so we've
been going strong ever since and we have
two community partners one is Food Not
Bombs the other one is a live to give
and so we partnered with them to give
meals to the homeless and give meals to
families who have been affected by the
school closures and things like that
absolutely well we're so excited to be
here I'm so excited to be here I'm a
regular for sure that so coming up later
in the show I want to talk about health
and wellness because there's still a
virus out there as long and want to make
sure you guys are safe and healthy too
so stay tuned I love it hey rocky I
don't mean to complain but yesterday it
was about strawberry pie right and we
said hey come back to the station we
want to see you so today you can totally
redeem yourself because it looks great
there exactly all right hey thanks Rocky
let's move